Apple finally gave us a lower price
large screen MacBook and I think that
it's going to be the best-selling
MacBook for the remainder of 2023 but
with that said if you watch their WWDC
announcement there are a lot of things
that they flat out did not mention so if
you're thinking about buying one of
these here are nine things that you need
to know especially if you haven't bought
a Mac for a while now the first one has
got to do with the price tag when Apple
showed off that 12.99 price most of us
were really surprised now if that seems
like it's just a hundred dollars more
than when Apple launched the M2 13-inch
MacBook Air well that is not exactly
correct while the M2 13-inch air did
launch at 11.99 that model actually was
binned meaning that it had less
performance with that M2 Chip and if you
wanted to unlock the full performance
you would have to spend an extra one
hundred dollars bringing up to that same
12.99 that the 15 inch just launched at
now I was expecting the same thing for
the 15 inch and I was surprised when I
went to the order page and I didn't see
that little upgrade but instead it says
that it comes with a full 10 core GPU
which is awesome now Apple did lower the
price of the 13 inch by a hundred
dollars so technically there's a 200
base starting difference but if you're
ordering spec for a spec with the same
performance it's only a hundred dollar
difference and that is incredible now
the second thing that they didn't
mention and of course they wouldn't say
this is that you can actually buy the 15
inch right now from Amazon for 50 bucks
off both for the base model and the
upgraded SSD option I'll go ahead and
leave the link down below but the reason
I'm mentioning this is because a lot of
people don't know that you can buy it
from Amazon and you get the same exact
warranty and you could still get
AppleCare on the device even if you
don't buy it from Apple which is why a
lot of people just go to Apple to buy it
because they're not informed and there's
some other good news about AppleCare
that I'll cover in just a bit now the
third thing is the performance now yes
the 15 inch has the same M2 Chip as the
13-inch MacBook Air it is also fanless
but when you go over their spec page
they list the same performance for both
machines but from what we have found is
that the M2 13-inch MacBook Air does
throttle quite a bit and fairly fast if
you're putting in heavy loads because of
its thin and light design especially
with that redesign but with the 15 inch
model this thing is going to be a little
bit thicker it's also larger and the way
that the cooling works is that chip
heats up and then the heat spreads
across the chassis so you will get a bit
more performance now we actually did a
video getting better performance from
the 13 inch using multiple different
methods and some of them were super
simple than just attaching a pad to the
bottom or putting on a laptop stand and
we got into some crazier ones so if you
guys want to see that we'll have that
linked at the end of the video as for
number four we have battery size now at
the event Apple said that this thing
gets 18 hours of battery life just like
the 13 inch model and that disappointed
some people because we were all
expecting better battery life from this
larger device now what they did not
mention is the actual size and if we dig
through the fine details in the compare
tool that is where we find the Watt
hours the 15 inch has a 66.5 watt hour
battery compared to
52.6 and that is over 26
larger now what weird with apple is that
they like to have these battery life
kind of points that they just show off
for example with the Apple watch they
have the same battery life across many
generations whereas in the real world
the series 7 had way better Real World
battery than Series 6 and 8 got even
better but they quoted the same and the
same thing goes for the M1 13-inch
MacBook Air it has quite a bit of
smaller battery but they rated the same
and of course that is with video
playback with lower brightness not on
the web so that number is not accurate
and what we have seen is with these
larger batteries your real world battery
life will actually be better so if
you're trying to decide between
different models keep that in mind the
15 inch one will be really great the
fifth thing they didn't mention is that
there is a new charging adapter and you
have to be very careful with what you
purchase and I will explain
when they launched this new machine and
we went to the website we saw that
there's a 70 watt adapter that is now
available and it replaces their previous
slightly lower one and that is probably
to get to 50 charge in 30 minutes on
this new machine now if you're getting a
base 13 inch air you actually have to
pay an additional 20 bucks to get that
fast charger or you have the option of
the Dual charger whereas with the 15
inch that doesn't cost you anything
extra and you don't have that very slow
limited charger as an option so that
makes the 15 inch an even better value
but what I have to point out to you guys
is that if you don't know which one you
should choose and the Dual charger
sounds really good it's a 35 watt right
so if you you know double that well that
seems like it's a 70 watt but that's not
the case even on the full page for this
charger they don't really give you any
additional information about it which I
think kind of suck they don't tell you
this that if you are using this compact
dual charger and you plug in your Mac
along with the iPhone or an iPad each
device will receive just 17.5 watts of
charging and that is going to take a
very long time compared to 70 Watts you
guys see that difference it is massive
so what I would say is even though this
seems convenient get that 70 watt one
because you can always plug your iPhone
or iPad directly into the MacBook itself
and plug that in that is a much better
deal now the next one is that the brand
new 2023 15-inch Air does not come with
Wi-Fi 6E and I will explain why this is
kind of weird now it does have Bluetooth
5.3 which is great if you're going to be
pairing it with the new Apple watch or
with new airpods but it still has Wi-Fi
6 just like the m213 inch which came out
about a year ago or so now you would say
what has the same M2 Chip but the weird
thing is is that the M2 Mac Mini that
starts at 599 dollars or even 4.99 with
an educational discount actually has
Wi-Fi 60 built into it so this seems
more like a software lock than an actual
good reason to do that now if you say
you don't need Wi-Fi 6E well I actually
made a full video comparing Wi-Fi 60 in
a Mac compared to older one like the 15
inch or older chipset with Wi-Fi 6 and
even if you have Wi-Fi 5 the speed
difference that I got was absolutely
incredible and the same thing with the
range because the you know Mac Mini or
the other Macs that have Wi-Fi 6C
capability the 5x5 still has twice the
bandwidth available with better
reception so if you're trying to
consider maybe an M2 Pro 14 inch or the
15 inch but definitely you want to
consider this as for number seven the
next thing they did not mention is that
the base 256 gigabyte model doesn't have
the same performance as the 512 gig and
above now I know my Apple would not want
to tell you this and if you've been
following our Channel last year with a
13 inch launched we took that thing
apart we saw that it only had one SSD
wait for a chip on there instead of two
now the significance of that is the
transfer speed is about half and you
might say I don't need big fast transfer
speed but in real world performance if
you're transferring large files it can
slow down dramatically worse than half
and then if you're multitasking you have
a couple programs open and some web
browsing tabs your real world
performance also goes down because the
SSD is used for swap memory now people
have asked why would Apple do this
whereas the M1 based products didn't
have this issue while the M1 required
two little SSD chips whereas the M2 is
built to not require it and if we look
at the prices for SSD chips the 128
gigabyte one actually costs more than a
256 so if Apple used two of these like
they did before it would more than
double the cost compared to just using
one so they're definitely saving money
but I wish at least they told you the
performance difference on their website
so I would strongly recommend upgrading
to 512. now number eight is a positive
one and it has to do with Apple Care Now
if you haven't bought a Mac for a while
you might think you have to go to Apple
you have to prepay a bunch of money but
that is not the case the program's
gotten way better first off if you buy
an Amazon you don't even have to add
Apple Care there or any other warranties
once you get your Mac you could just go
into your system settings and in general
and it will give you how many days you
have left to buy it and you can buy it
right there from at home and the cool
thing is you can now get it within 60
days of your new Mac instead of 30 and
even cooler than that it no longer
expires after three years where a lot of
Macs will be just fine but you can have
it run indefinitely if you keep the Mac
for five years six years seven years
it'll basically keep going until you
cancel it so you don't have to just have
a three year coverage and pay 229 up
front you could do 80 bucks a year and
you also have unlimited incidents of
accidental damage protection so it's
only not only one or two a year and it's
99 bucks for a body or screen
replacement or 300 bucks for a whole new
Mac and I think this is the best
warranty and insurance in the industry
and I wish Apple actually talked about
this on stage now the last one for
number nine is a simple one but people
keep asking me about it I keep replying
and that is which color they should get
now it's a little bit funny but my
personal favorite is the midnight color
because it's beautiful but I would not
recommend anybody buying it because it
is an absolute fingerprint magnet and
not only a fingerprint magnet it is hard
to get the fingerprints off and once you
do as soon as you touch it they come
right back so personally I would say go
for the Starlight because it looks great
it's a newer color and you'd have to
deal with any of these issues so thank
you guys for watching you guys could
check out the links down below go ahead
and click that Circle above to subscribe
because we have these ordered we're
gonna make a bunch of videos using
different real world programs check out
that video and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]